الاشتباكات هنا على اشدها ليس بالغازات
والحجاره فقط بل بالالفاظ ايضا فبينما يصف
عمران خان الحكومه الباكستانيه باللصوص
تشبه الاخيره بالفار المختبئ في جحره
اعلم ان كل الاشخاص الموجودين في السلطه
اليوم رئيس الوزراء شهباز شريف وزيره
الداخليه اضافه لشخص من المخابرات هم
الذين خططوا للهجوم على حياته التصعيد
الاخير بين خان والحكومه ليس وليد الايام
القليله الماضي بل نتيجه صراع على السلطه
بدا بالاطاحه بخان قانونيا عبر البرلمان
ففي ابريل من العام الماضي حجب البرلمان
الثقه عن خان وفي اغسطس اتهمته الشرطه
بتهم تتعلق بالارهاب والفساد امر اغضب
انصاره ليتعهدوا بالسيطره على العاصمه في
نوفمبر من العام نفسه تعرض خان لعمليه
اغتيال لتبدا شراره المواجهه الاخيره
نهايه فبراير الماضي بمذكره اعت قال تتعلق
بقبول هدايا غير مشروعه
الحكومه الباكستانيه تؤكد ان قرار القاء
القبض على خان قضائي مستقل وليس له علاقه
بادعاءات عمران خان حول حرمانه وحسبه من
خوض الانتخابات المقبله انتخابات يفصل
البلاد عنها نفق بدايته تقتض بمواجهات
الطرفين وقد تحجب الضوء في نهايته اذا ما
احتدم الصراع رائد المصطفى العربيه